it's been a week last week I asked you
to distract me oh so scared I'm shaking
shaking I'm scared that's a joke by the
way I'm not actually scared this is me
fake shaking because in reality I'm
confident in myself and my own abilities
that anything that will be said in this
district it's going to be a load of
garbage now of course you guys are just
idiots I asked you to do a diss track
and I get this you laughs you lose
pewdiepie original [ __ ] great ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha what else do we got
YouTube order ha ha Waymon anyway it's
an urban dictionary now a rare species
of wam and they usually need more
attention slash expect than other women
also some of them are an idiot it's math
related to science are an Indian okay
good job I'll take that you know he's an
handsome man he's a beautiful man
hey his torso may be abnormally small
but goddamn I'll take it all right can
we get to the goddamn diss track stop
distracting me oh here we go here's a
diss track ok here we go
ok doing that doing the old read off the
phone thing oddly what what the [ __ ] did
he say
let me see those oh [ __ ] you you're
[ __ ] ugly how dare you you know what
I don't even care this is kind of kinky
and funky I mean funky it is tasty
it is goddamn tasty I put vanilla beard
on okay Oh Dolan dark made one oh good
let's see what this meme meme account
dude what do you my name a Jeff huh is
that what you gon make a diss track on
me best your next job is to submit your
diss track on me
practices oh no he better not yet
rice guy this is a PewDiePie beat his
ass so hard but he'll piss black oh man
I've only just begun don't worry this
videos not 1001 PewDiePie also known as
Felix Kjellberg I wish the Titanic hit
you are not the iceberg Oh are you doing
here
in the corner of the video in your
little square God there goes another one
no originality you stillness from rice
cap oh look it's my favorite Chiba he
rides the beat about as well as nuba
there's the fat one slacking again how
many reactions now seven eight nine ten
this whole trend is really [ __ ] lame
why did I write this now I'm literally
just the same if you're a youtuber
please stop rapping what's the point
you've only got nine-year-old clapping
true it's true
damn that was not it that doesn't even
in a diss on me is destined the whole
shitty district even like mainstream
artists are buying into this now like
Katy Perry and taste way are just making
these bad songs they're just bad just
make a decent song it leads we're gonna
make a diss track makes a little decent
song like this song it's a lyrical
genius
this song is Mozart of our modern time
Doland darker more like dolan mozar cuz
it's good it's really good but just look
like i'm an imprisoned isn't it they let
me keep my jacket at least thank you I
mean following you for 5 years
oh that's so sweet what a beautiful
picture that's when I actually looked
attractive thank you very much
that's an amazing fan art can I get the
disk tracks though
Oh yo I'm JB pie your violin future pile
of poop disguise is a human nine time
for you to cry you killed Cupid why he
was trying to help you to find the girl
that took one look at you puked and
committed suicide just like your
channels grown so then you banned and
told the girl they mark SIA that you pay
her lots yet an act like your date you
had to enlist your sister so who you
calling sister Pfister mister my
channels existing just to list a bunch
of clickbait titles for wit nothing
inside because I just don't know how to
frickin quit while I'm behind but maybe
I'm being too hard on little Felix K now
I mean Zayn has been through a lot in
recent days I don't think maybe we
should share to stop to breathe and lay
off of him should I say they lay him off
like Disney hey you suck at what you do
the only reason that you're at the top
the fact that hot air rises they need a
bull the bits of back and stop whack us
off the charts a pointless is chasing
the wind I hear you're into Christmas
but you don't need a man just look in
the mirror oh it was trash your beard is
trash and I cannot see okay listen now
you step it over the line you see this
you can't call my beard fresh when
you're looking like a ginger reject okay
what the [ __ ] is that
put them up next to each other okay I'm
sorry you just legitimize your entire
district okay I was on board for a
minute but god damn it you just you
trashed yourself you ruined yourself I'm
sorry to say it here it is trash and I
cannot see why anyone likes you I'm here
to bash up I cannot see retire you
frosty headed Punk before I get ahead of
us
tactic witness said it better yourself
away throw Peter price stocks he's sold
child nations
he probably just makes videos for money
and I don't know he's just so stupid
okay his beard does connect a lot better
actually now that I see it he does have
this problem here that it doesn't go
under sides why is the beard thing the
only thing that bothers me that was good
that was really good well done sage well
done legit better than most of these
districts all right here we go another
just right okay bring it on Felix you
smell like fish I don't smell like fish
by the way that's that's not accurate I
have to come clean here miss call me the
guy dissing boo deep I didn't want to do
it really truly I don't enjoy breaking
up this down but a challenge was
presented so I'm gonna break the sound
and
about to be in everybody's you to
recommend it so Wall Street Journal take
notes and collective
[Music]
like jokes are you smell like fish is
that that's the chorus but you smell
okay so wait so you do wraps right and
you completely stole the flow of Eminem
good good job good job that's really
impressive I'm really impressed by your
rap skills I'm sure keep keep doing that
and I'm sure you'll go big places take
back about what you said about me
smelling like a fish
if you're gonna rhyme outwits then don't
pronounce it wrong I'm nitpicking i love
pewdiepie now you don't know you don't
how dare you say that me yes
well then that's awesome alright another
15 so that's why I both look you didn't
have to tell me that I can see that from
your pimple yes face bring it run - [ __ ]
oh no he's got that M&M poster let's
talk about this [ __ ] PewDiePie
you probably heard of this YouTube guy
for a million but you million per video
Epic Meal Time looking at so here we go
maybe five becoming with the try not to
laugh couple inches no original content
e7 on the layers just killing it for
really he's run out of any silly so it
has become a goal here we go Joe Carter
every single video became an Aussie and
lost ur he show moved out of the club
piece to do ever since then your
channels benign show
fro this is really a pro all these
distraction but if it's no Beauty fine
even though your channels dying you
still managed to get me and click on
your lies I don't know why I really
wanna die your content so sure it makes
me want to cry I mean good flow
this guy had good flow I got a for a
fifteen-year-old that's pretty good
all right whatever gap I'll grande did
one what is it's your host killer
keemstar and today I'll be reporting the
fall of PewDiePie 0 deaths won't be true
when I'm done with this friend
now I'm sure but for you I have zero
respect there's a question where did the
original content go if you run out of
ideas why three years ago you laugh you
lose I'm gonna make
and lose make fun of Jews now you're all
over the news
yes and I heard you are an asset what's
wrong with you stretching to ten minutes
with Lennox and Reverend like no one's
not least thanks to you scary
advertisers are less scare PewDiePie -
no one wants it anyway naturally by
being more family-friendly
well too bad none of your videos are
comedy friendly Oh you spent rigid
spheres think that makes you cool yeah
it's not like you're starting fire in
your backyard
oh oh oh well I guess I got a semi in
this joke
great that Lena's dead please stop
who in their right mind would think old
memes are still funny
JK pewdiepie I love you are devastating
I was [ __ ] awesome well then it's one
got a lot of dislike sorry I imagine
it's really good the game
[Music]
you contents dry and you've got the
white is little did you know this is the
least of your fears on exposed I'm
joining team ten all you do is keep bait
again and again where's your puke on you
it seems like you post anything to make
some followers but when they're grown
sorry it's a bit different which I
appreciate
didn't make my date card or anything but
you know sorry for real really
appreciate you guys making these I love
watching this stuff it's really fun I'm
glad I have an army of people that can
just make original content for me well I
just react to it I know that's like a
meme but at the same time it's pretty
cool what should we do for next week
what's next week challenge huh make
something physical not just a painting
or a drawing or some something like that
make something out in the real world out
there and take a picture of it and send
it to me and I will judge it from a
scale from one to ten most likely you
will not get a ten but I will accept any
challenge show the impact of the squad
fam in the world it could be a video it
could be a picture it could be anything
you like baby but that's it for me for
now leave a like if you enjoyed watching
squad fam out